Here we have our data from our caffeine and reaction time experiment. The
caffeine group is called the experimental group and the no-caffeine group is
called the placebo or control group. We just mention the mean, which is another
statistical tool that we use in psychological experiments. The mean is the
average of all scores. So for our caffeine and reaction time experiment we took
each individuals reaction time and got an average. So for our experimental
group the average or mean score on reaction time was 0.3527 seconds. And for
our control or placebo group, our average reaction was 0.5621. So what does
this difference mean? We ran another statistical test and we found that the
difference between the experimental group and the control group was
statistically significant. But what does that mean? It means that it is highly
unlikely that the scores we observed were due by chance. So again in this
caffeine and reaction study we can say the signicant difference between point
three and point five seconds occurred most likely because of the caffeine and
not because of some other variable.